hi I'm Greg and I'm Tarek Tarek yes my
friends from acting class yes yes I am
and serese cut a few unto hot Instagram
snapchat and Twitter follow them there
is please please for the love of God
just do it why do I get what I'm so
thirsty I really not I'm means thirsty
for you to have folders I'm not thirsty
for you I'm gonna need that clip so a
few people requested it but the first
one I came in his section session this
action action yeah I lost the signal me
Drita difficut people need real names
heating up like Greg jar or tarik you
know a common name
[Music]
how could you let Bowser photograph just
an away you're hired they're gonna snap
away from it what are you doing
if you don't have a gal and swagger hell
oh excuse me hey hey go go oh yeah I
walk thing I really must have words with
you on behalf of your twin brother drew
what mean brother
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
over here would make enough doctor this
place is amazing it's nice like a jean
I'm not really interested only one
conclusion continue the family tradition
you and me no let that light behind me
just one oh brother
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay so the first trailer I saw this
movie it was about him trying to take
because I guess you were so a government
our yeah that's what I thought to it
yeah he's trying to he's trying to take
down a like this villain who steals
diamonds be kind of like out of the ease
it's like his whole buildings based
around the 80s and now he has this twin
brother we didn't know about they were
getting two new characters in here the
twin brother seems like he's out of the
80s as well yeah it's really fun I love
a secret playing both of it I know I
don't like yeah okay you Carell doing
two character voices in this film and
like do better to play up Steve Carell
Steve Carell and I really like how the
brother that using the - shady than to
be a criminal you know but he's like way
more sexy way more like his lifestyle
the way more lavish yeah radish got the
whole ham and go yeah big flow like I'm
that brother you're my brother you know
my brothers like grew unlike the drew
you don't do I'm like this sexy sexy you
know liar going I am like I got I just
I'm everything I my brother's like he's
like whatever doesn't he like was really
similar to you oh my god oh my god oh my
god can you like a 10 and my brothers
like these are your group a little like
like a - like a to the grew - nothing
grows to do how dare you look at ready
that's
sorry guys like yeah there's a
despicable mood me movie looks really
good it looks funny minions are still
involved and really adds about that poor
little things then they're amazing I
feel like some people hate the minions
now see that's why I didn't watch the
minions movie because I felt like I'm
gonna hate the minions if I watch a
whole movie of them out to me that's
true that is it I mean there's little
moments really make the whole film you
know the little anguish bpai like oh yes
it's still cute and adorable open it at
birth moments like you said if it's like
a whole movie and like that's just going
to get annoying after a while it's like
it's intentionally a side character you
know there's a lot of you'll hate the
minions now but I still think they're
not there they're amazed I didn't bug an
adorable yeah they should definitely
teach a minion language class but how to
speak like them like yo that would make
none of that up good thing you know
what's great about the despicable Me
movies I think people kind of forget
about is that the first two when you
watch the trail isn't even the setups of
the film they seem like they're just
going to be wacky comedies that are
highly stylized animation but there's
always a heart at the end of it yeah
very like eat like you touched on your
hug on your heart like the first ones
about him being a dad
yeah second when he falls in love Dylan
why not probably gonna have to deal with
jealousy with his brother and you know
me going yeah keep dishing these out man
get all the family members yeah yeah you
know it's all these family things now
it's like room house people introduced
into his life that become family now
we're seeing grooves actual bloodline
and family it's going to be fun I like
this one it was cool I mean this is a
kids movie so I don't want to go too
vulgar with what I'm about to say true
but something tells me drew is gonna
bone bruise wife yo I saw that right I
was like oh like his hands already on
her back
that's gonna get a nun I can't say the
amount of girlfriends my brother has
passed
I have boned ridiculous really yeah
there it is like let this email like
this I know what okay but what's funny
is I've never felt guilty about a single
one of them Wow mmm you never have a
soul but if he does that to me you can
get to me just like that just like they
don't see that this is a double standard
at all not different you know different
different program really is different
for me what's different
well I just I mean he's a - so he should
accept it damn that's called a friend as
gold blood it's like you can't do
justice ahead no college - it's hard for
me to find love woman our caucus
underneath of me I never know if they
just want me for my looks or if they
actually want me for me so much find a
woman want like he only gets women who
like him for him because all he has to
work on this is personality which is
okay must be really rough even me it
must be real rough for you yeah it's
really rough on four out some for you
make some thanks thanks - why do girls
kids never age that's true I've been the
same age decision adopted later the
oldest one shouldn't she be going to
should you be like pass high schoolers
know what is the timeframe that these
movies are taking place really yeah
that's not really to them yeah yeah
we're going this actually looks like
it's shot that we're looking at right
now she looks like the first shopper
shopper baby you know like when they
first get that kids are all aging
oh they were to change that clothes all
right this looks like it's gonna be fun
got to good story lights up you got a
new villain played by Trey Parker one of
the co-creators of South Park and now
you got the Guru's brother I feel like
when the two stories come together you
have to work together to catch this guy
or maybe the villain is involved with
grooves brother in some way some what it
make it look like though that drew
grooves brother
drew is not as good at this until any
thing and now this one is is that mean
grow quickly yeah grow Andrew but maybe
there's a little plot line there so I'm
hoping there'd be like
you don't want this life bro submit any
life you don't need it bro is really
dark
yeah to tickle me finally embraces its
villainous theme to be able super dark
hello man's not for children anymore I
hope there's a scene at the end where
there's just a montage of groom eating
his whole family and they're off they
all rhyme with group dolana GRU is
really blue
boom le poop it would be a fool in
trivia poops and there's dark heavy
drama and I guess see the minion
thinking fun with it yeah oh yeah look
at itok alright guys well thank you to
that name that I remembered had exactly
how to pronounce just such in discussion
session I think that's a move when you
like wipe your butt is yeah so like do
it one wipe so how he's like three
different and why it's interesting I
want to talk about this anymore channel
you can subscribe to the real reject you
do that Tariq Carrick Teradek doe is
that goes our ego yeah it'd be your rap
name pterodactyl yo I'm in you to reject
Oh yo to Rica to us to Instagram Twitter
snapchat he's not desperate but all in
its got your back thanks man I got your
back
not just my favorite